and martin rees and we're in Cambridge
University where I work and I'm an
astronomer and astrophysicist and my
professional interest has been in trying
to understand cosmic phenomena and how
our universe has evolved over 13.8
billion years from some mysterious hot
dense beginning the Big Bang to its
present complex States where we have
this cosmic panorama and its biosphere
which we are apart so that's my science
but I'm also interested in the more
human aspects of our civilization and
how we can use such a human benefit and
avoid its downsides
it's wonderful how we've understood more
about universe and about science
generally but I've been in my later
years engaged in discussions with
scientists about how we can use science
for maximum benefit and avoid the risks
and it's led me to realize that this
century is very special even in the
cosmic perspective the Earth's exist for
45 million centuries but this is the
first where one species our species is
empowered by technology to change the
whole planet and we are so numerous and
so demanding of energy resources that we
make electively be despoiling the planet
and leaving a depleted world for future
generations but on the upside our
technology may allow us to make a
transition from a earth-based species to
a species where there are few people a
few intelligences living on Mars and
maybe beyond so there are very exciting
possibilities and these are addressed in
a book I've written published in October
2018 called on the future and I address
from a perspective of a scientist what
these issues are how we can deal with
climate change and population pressures
and also how we can ensure that
technology like bio cyber and AI are
used to human benefit and we avoid the
downside
and I think we do need to worry because
there are very big stakes
the technologies we have now are very
powerful indeed but that means the risks
are also very large and so it's a
mixture of light and shade in my book I
discuss all the potentialities but also
the risks and at the end of the book I
discuss also the future of science
itself are they going to be limits to
what the human brain can understand we
in some sense hit the buffers in our
understanding of science and also the
future of space technology will we be
able to go beyond the earth or is it
best just to leave that to robots and
also I discuss what the responsibilities
of scientists are we have a special
understanding of the fruits of
technology but of course we scientists
don't have any special insight into
ethics or economics
so we are their just citizens so I write
Park as a scientist that partly has a
rather anxious member of the human race
and also was a university teacher who is
privileged have access to the next
generation and to hope to influence them
so that they care about the long-term
future in an era where too much of
politics is taken up with short term
immediate concerns